nyle dimarco joins Chippendales and et's  got the first look the Dancing with the  Stars and America's Next Top Model champ  just recently announced he will be  strutting his stuff for the Las Vegas  show this fall I think what I'm most  looking forward to is being the host and  I don't know if they've ever actually  had a deaf host before nyle is in fact  the world-famous show's first ever deaf  celebrity host I will be teaching some  ladies in the audience some sign  language and et got a sneak peek behind  the scenes as the 27 year old model  tried on the signature Chippendales  bowtie collar and cuffs I think what the  fans should expect that there'll be a  lot of fun for myself and the rest of  the Chippendales team they will see some  skin but if they want to see more they  have to come to the show nyle will be  taking his rippling abs to the Rio on  the Las Vegas Strip starting September  22nd